the recent Nobel Committee has decided
that the Nobel Peace Prize in 2012 is to
be awarded to the European Union the
Union and its foreigners have over six
decades contributed to the advancement
of peace and reconciliation democracy
and human rights
while very proud that we receive this
Nobel Prize a recognition of the work of
the European Union as a peacemaker it
was with great emotion that I received
news of the world of Nobel Peace Prize
to the opinion in NASA scientist ovation
Schiedam he the outpatient union
movement we had some information about
the you being among the most probable
candidates for winning the cross this
year but then the situation was similar
also in earlier years when the decision
was officially announced the first
reaction was total I would say
jubilation we we agreed that this is
something that will change also our
lives for the coming weeks
with this a very thorough process a very
secret process among the five members
around this table which has ended with
always a unanimous decision it's a long
process this year it was not
particularly difficult because it was
obvious because it situation in Europe
that
a message had to come from somewhere it
was a very interesting coincident that
my what the painting was consisting of
twelve rectangles and jokingly - they
asked me if I had had some cool got the
price before that it's quite fantastic
to have this huge organization as an
ending on Mercury here in the novel
after 23 years working so it's very nice
this ceremony is my last one and it was
and it's a huge organization to deal
with they have three different
institutions and they have different
wishes all of them higher security and
very high security which also interfere
in everything
normally they arrive the day before they
are they have a press conference which
is old always a big thing for the press
a huge shower from the press and then
they go to this room to sign all the
formal documents so that they can
receive the gold medal which is real
gold medal and the prize money it's
going to be an important speech
officially for the European Union the my
role with other colleagues in the past
weeks have has been to find the right
words to translate as it were what the
president wants to say tomorrow on the
10th of December in Moscow the next day
the formal ceremony
we not only received three presidents
representing the European Union we also
receive 20 heads of state
no maturities royal highnesses state and
governments excellencies ladies and
gentlemen the Nobel laureate welcome to
Oslo and thank you for bringing so many
heads of state and governments along
with you
congratulations for the big prize
it is with humility and gratitude that
we stand here together to receive this
award on behalf of the European Union at
a time of uncertainty this day reminds
people across Europe in the world of the
union's fundamental purpose to further
the fraternity between European nations
now and in the future to constant
negotiations on ever more topics between
ever more countries and it's the golden
rule of Romani muir for a dispute a
routing table you see rashon tabata
better fight around the table than on a
battlefield it's being an au pair chefs
we share death European I'm proud to be
European
our quest for European unity is not a
perfect work of art it is working
progress that demands constant and
diligent standing it is not an end in
itself but it means to hire and in many
ways it attests to the quest for a
cosmopolitan order in which one person's
game does not need to be another
person's pain in which abiding by common
norms serves universal values that is
why despite its imperfections the
European Union can be and indeed is a
powerful inspiration for many around the
world and today one of the most visible
symbols of our unity is in everyone's
hands it is zero the currency of our
European Union we will stand by it after
the Second World War the reconciliation
between Germany and France laid the very
foundations for European integration the
reconciliation between Germany and
France is probably the most dramatic
example in the history to show that war
and conflict can be turned solve rapidly
into peace and cooperation
it was one of the most moving moments in
a noble history it was not planned the
two presents just did it and opportunity
remember that the German Chancellor and
French president bit wrong and called it
the same invader repeating this now is
very symbolic because we don't know what
will happen in Europe actually it is a
fabulous tradition and it goes back
nearly two decades now then after the
laureates received the Nobel Peace Prize
we have an opportunity to sit down with
them and talk for an hour in a live
broadcast that's seen all around the
world giving them a chance to explain
their work and their views of surprise
and also giving people a chance to learn
a little bit more inevitably about some
of the most interesting people and some
of most important work that's being done
anywhere north and after that is this
traditional dinner at the Grand Hotel
with the torch lighting passing the
hotel and the suite where the
prizewinners are living yesterday it was
a huge crowd they're actually bigger
than what is normal and that was very
good for us in committee today to see it
went very well I think it is one of the
most important days in the noble history
because this price is really about what
Alfred Nobel wrote in his will namely
about fraternity between nations and
having peace congress's which was very
important at the time when he lived
today a peace Congress is really to sit
around the table find compromises and in
that respect European Union has been a
continued peace commerce I think the
European Union has a lot of chances but
only if we stick together and if we not
allowed that we are divided in 27 pieces
you